[Music]
welcome everybody to the endgame lecture
tonight and I'm glad to see a good
attendance here and we're going to work
about you know your endgame fish and
there are a lot of important positions
that you need to know and we're going to
start off we have some really strong
players in the audience I want to
mention some 2,100 almost 2200 so so
this is a really good strong turnout we
have here tonight and the position
number one please take a look at the
screen here and it's white to play and
what is the evaluation of this position
you have to know your opposite color
endgames this is very very important
today we're going to work on a lot of
this up of the colors and Bishop end
games to see if you feel comfortable
with this so what do you think that's
obvious of course of course of course of
course we know that absolutely
absolutely why this playing for a wheel
you've got two extra parts to central
pawns right and black is trying to make
a draw somehow but the question is how
how this is going to work out okay how
this thing is going to simply unfold
here okay
so let's think about this
let's think about this and if you allow
it please raise your hand but I need a
complete answer here okay why to play oh
sheesh listen carefully why'd you play
and what is the evaluation of this
position this is a draw it's a win for
white obviously black cannot win right
so please raise your hand if you think
you have the complete answer
okay what's the evaluation of this
position with white to move triple zeros
okay okay
ah what is the method of doing the
triple zeros then he sacrificed so
basically he suggesting if I Bishop g4
and claiming that he can stay on this
diagonal to make a draw right do you
agree with him do you guys agree with
that that you cannot make a draw like
this are your no okay let's let's see
let's I want to give you guys a chance a
little bit I want to give you guys live
here so this setup that does our student
here mentions is this sufficient enough
to make a draw I can see it's undecided
yes see people are not sure about this
that's why it's important to do this
position because you will be comfortable
you'll be comfortable about this okay
when you know how to know like this
could be instantaneous for you would not
a method after I show you this so this
is actually not the right way to hold
the position I will show you the winning
plan here I go here
you sit right did you see my walk my
walk to f6 do you see that and now
actually I don't even have to do the
walk because you are simply in loop the
wrong everybody familiar with looks
along absolutely so this is a Zook okay
and ii fix comes in it's losing so
unfortunately that was a good try but
that's not going to work so first of all
is this a holdable position even can you
even hold this position huh ah smart guy
immediately analyzed enough analyze
large you an excellent ok
this position is a draw you have three
ways to hold this from the back back
from the side which he did and the third
one is from the front at defend from the
front what is that mean so-so so let's
say he goes here it has to be this
position so you go Bishop h5 now he
pushes this and this is your defense
from the front ok this is the only way
to start to to connected past pounds
another rule you must know if the pawn
which is the sixth rank forget about it
if the pawn which is 6 trunk you are
going to lose ok so that's the idea if
the pawn which is 6 and no chance ok so
remember that so the only way to do is
like this because if you sit you go here
if you go c6 you take take take that's
it
anything goes here
and that's locate dead blockade you know
you cannot win this all right so the
only way to defend is you have to manage
to get the bishop to f7 okay and if I
plate you put the bishop on epsilon okay
so original position is actually black
to move here okay
so it's black to move and you have to
get the bishop to the front if it
doesn't push right you attack attacking
this if it moves you take so as to go
here and you go here eighty-six you just
take if it goes here you put the black
egg got it all right so that's the
position you have to remember when the
past pawns are going you attack from the
front okay you simply attack from the
front got it
any questions moving forward what is the
likelihood of this position here with
black to move let's say or it doesn't
matter the move to Bahamas but what's
the evaluation of this position
it's black to move I'm going to make it
black to move for you again using the
same knowledge okay you are using the
same exact knowledge so what would be
the idea here
is this is this win or draw Goku because
if we exchange a city plays like h5 to
Portland context context we get the
additionally about it depend upon it
again so then if we ever get the G and H
on VN position electro fishing pimp
activity hot and this is so it's a draw
what's the your move your go cool
excellent job yes the correct note here
is h5 and evaluation is a draw because
the only way for Y to make progress is
to pay g4 and if you place default
eutychus if it takes this way all you
gotta do is sit you sit
okay you sit if it pushes you go here
and then you cannot do anything if you
press f5 you locking it okay if it goes
f5 you're taking it all right so that's
why he's going to give us this try now
how are you guys going to hold this
Aashish you're going from the back again
what's the defense here I told you it's
not the back
it's what the front everybody King g6
excellent keep working
excellent job
attack attack the target remember always
attack the target
now you go wrong you're going to regret
it
who said king f7 go cool actually
actually actually King f7 is also a draw
there is a reason why the reason why
because when he gets this he doesn't
have a way to cross on h6 yunpeng go
cool you got lucky right here because
the King cannot access the h6 squared
because he's on the edge of the board
everybody understand that Arjuna the
King cannot you - King gets on a ship
it's going to be a win but he cannot do
that so it's going to be a draw you just
sitting on it and it because here you're
going to sacrifice but more professional
approach here is king h7 you sit he goes
here a ship f7 there we go
and you're attacking the pump on h5 got
it and he is going to have lots of
difficulties defending a position like
this because now the to win the position
like this because e how can he win this
he is going to sit what is the only move
here EA is trying to put you in the souk
Sivan can you accomplish that nope you
say you stay on that diagonal so
learning defend from the front everybody
you understand always defend from the
front in this kind of opposite color
endgame positions okay that is the rule
that is the rule okay for you to
remember I have a position for you this
happened actually in a very in a game
between strong players so
my question to you here is what is the
evaluation of a position like this
Wow wait five two four five students
here six seven you thinking it and other
people think it's kg8 obviously right
okay I have a very easy way for you to
understand what the correct move is in
order to win a position like this you're
going to have to move his bishop from
the long diagonal which is this right to
the short diagonal okay from the long
diagonal you have to move it to the
short diagonal that's what you got to do
got it so but when you do this you go
you want to control the squares okay
on the way you want to control the
squares got it so that's why you want to
try to do that to control okay TMG is
the correct move because you stay where
you need to stay okay so he sits he sits
he sits past number one accomplished we
are moving the bishop from the long
diagonal so he goes here or doesn't
matter except here jungle here so he
goes here now with moved in from the
long diagonal to the short diagonal now
how are we going to win this I like this
should be - I like this nice touch there
should be two here cutting back into
Suk's one can I go to g7 because you
take an angle here as well so he has to
move the king he can't go there has to
go here and now you go Bishop g7 easy
victory okay any questions everybody
understand the concept of moving the
bishop from the long diagonal to the
short diagonal you got that concept
it it's actually that's a good question
if one is only seven here then this
would be the short diagonal right and I
think it's going to be a draw because he
is enough squares so if this ship has
more than two squares you have three
squares it's going to be draw actually
okay so so to speak
let's just make this a little bit more
clear for everybody this is your
question right so the position is like
this is this a win or a draw so this is
if you go here right he just sits so
you're going to be accomplishing this
same concept right you're going to kick
him you're going to go away you're going
to kick him you're going to go here
right and then if you go see if there is
no way for you to hook occupy all the
squares but actually I know if it was
here he has this move only move here
because here the only movie
yeah that's the idea okay to remember
yeah this is honor so it has to be three
squares or less okay three squares or
less if it's four squares here is four
squares this is going to be a draw well
not that draw but yet sure I mean you
still can go wrong here Adi
but yeah so okay moving forward I have a
very interesting position for you here
very clever position bishop and games
will be working a lot of bishop and
games okay white to play and win yeah
it's pretty obvious that we're trying to
win this position so so you know exactly
what you need to look for here how we
can try to accomplish this task ish guys
can we just focus let's focus here now
let's focus and I want you to raise your
hand when you can tell me exactly you
have it I don't want to go like little
by little and then we get to the answer
so I want somebody to be able to
actually give me like a pretty good
picture of the entire thing here okay
it's a win you know it's a win so how we
can accomplish that window okay a couple
of people raising their hands but it
seems like they're rushing I mean this
is a serious position this is almost
like a study you know I mean you have to
really be solution is like 10 moves here
yeah now if you think it's just a walk
in the park
I don't think you're looking at the best
defense for block here you're probably
looking you're probably you're so
focused on your own idea but you're not
acknowledging what he can try to do in
or acknowledging his ideas force the
defense out soon
everybody here does his king is going to
go on a six he's gotten a lot canola
tube put a vegetable not diagonal
because if you put this bishop here
you're going to win this if the bishop
is PRC you're going to win this the
whole task you how are you going to get
the bishop out there do you know how
much harder than it looks I believe
let's see okay in the back yes okay yeah
but there's one trick here she's
actually absolutely right very
interesting try you will win against
every single move except this
because now I go back you don't have
this unfortunately because I know your
idea right to get here
I go thank you and I cannot quit so you
will win actually good try though
excellent try because anything else she
is going to accomplish the task boom
boom boom okay and you're going to get
there got it
Bishop h4 right a Bishop g5 it doesn't
really matter I go here check I go here
no think because you have to move the
bishop I'm going to put the King this
this part is sort of obvious right
because then it goes back to b6 every
time you move the bishop away
guys guys can we do it in our head like
a test you know can discuss it what try
to do it in your head so we have to
bring the bishop back right that is the
idea we got to bring the bishop back so
we do not try to go back to d8 right now
the good news is now his King cannot
move because of the bishop a7 bishop be
a so he has to see it again right now
what do we do here guys now that nes
Bishop f4 Goku
- back we go sir Arjun I don't think
we're making progress
I want you to make progress okay well I
mean I mean I mean he has to be pretty
badly taken you know Bishop e7 excellent
excellent thinking I like that very good
now he goes here then you are here job
done
game over okay I know I'm just showing
you all the possibilities so yes to go
here okay okay now do you guys see a
difference between this position and the
original position who sees the
difference raise your hand raise your
hand who sees the difference here yes in
the back what is the difference Fischer
moved up does that make anything
different
okay so now you win a crucial temple and
that's how you're going to win the game
here by the crucial temple everybody got
it so what's the move of course
Bishop h4 temple so all this maneuvering
you did to win the temple to force them
to the weak square okay now he goes here
Bishop f2 I go here he goes here we're
moving the bishop from the mall diagonal
to the short diagonal right you got this
step 2 and now Bishop e3 and now if it
takes b8 Queens all right excellent okay
excellent I want to just do an over
review of what we cover today
okay so I think it was very important
because it seems like you were not so
familiar with this particular topic of
opposite color bishops and the same
color bishops this will be very valuable
for you in your tournament games because
you're going to be able to use these
ideas that you learned to be able to win
more and more games okay so the first
position we covered was when the past
pounds were on the fifth rank they were
about to approach so what was the first
defense we had to do attack from the
front or to attack from the front not
from the side not from the back from the
front second example was similar
position where you had to push the pawn
on h5 to restrict so if you go back and
watch these videos they will be uploaded
very soon you can watch this and you
will again understand you know the ideas
so you have to put a pawn on h5 to
restrict the position okay that was
another very important idea and the
third example we had where you had the
choice of the King on a fade under check
you go to the which side the long or
short short because we want to cover the
short diagonal in order to win a
positions like that on a seventh time
you always have to be able to push them
from the short diagonal from the long
diagonal to the short diagonal and of
course at the end we had this position
which I think was the most difficult
position from today's positions where
you have to reach the same position but
is Bishop to be on another square on g3
or anywhere else okay to be able to do
that so in order to do that we start out
with which move h4 keep working on yeah
Bishop e7
deflecting the bishop I know you're here
and you're going to put the future
behind it
absolutely absolutely okay excellent
okay good so practice this okay I would
recommend practice dispositions if you
have a friend or somebody you can set up
the position practice from both sides
where you have a passport on a six or
seven trunk to be able to use this ideas
okay so these are very important so
opposite color bishops you always have
to realize that you know even sometimes
positions with extra pawn is a winner I
forgot to mention the position with
extra power remember but it looked like
black and hold but white can I tell you
with a king on g6 and one to h6 pawn so
there are some positions where extra
pawn and you cannot hold there are some
positions to three extra pounds but
you're going to be able to make a draw
okay so make sure you remember that
[Music]
you
[Music]